in a fair democracy everyone's vote
should count equally but the method that
the United States uses to elect its
president called the Electoral College
violates this principle by making sure
that some people's votes are more equal
than others the Electoral College is
essentially the 538 votes that determine
who wins the presidency if these votes
were split evenly across a population
every 574 thousand people would be
represented by one vote but that's not
what happens because the Electoral
College doesn't give votes to people
only states which has some unfair
consequences for example there are
eleven point five million people in Ohio
so to fairly represent them it should
get 20 electoral votes but the Electoral
College doesn't give Ohio 20 votes it
only gets 18 - less than it should where
those other votes go to states like
Rhode Island plucky Rhode Island has 1.1
million people in it so it should have
about 2 votes but instead it gets for
those extra two votes that should be
representing Ohioans go to representing
Rhode Islanders instead why because
according to the rules of the Electoral
College every state no matter how few
people live there gets three votes to
start with before the rest are
distributed according to population
because of this rule there are a lot of
states with a few people that should
only have one or two votes for president
but instead get three or four so
Georgians Virginians Michiganders and
Jersey i'ts are each missing one vote
Pennsylvania North Carolinians Ohioans
and Hoosiers are missing two Floridians
are missing for New Yorkers five Texan
six and Californians are 10 votes short
of what they should get because of this
vote redistribution the Electoral
College essentially pretends that fewer
people live where they do and more
people live where they don't an American
who lives in one of these states has
their vote for president count for less
than an American who lives in one of
these states in some cases the Electoral
College bends the results just a little
but if you live in a particularly large
or small state it bends them a lot one
Vermonters vote according to the
electoral college is worth three Texans
votes and one Wyoming Heights vote is
worth four Californians
now whoa hold on there son you might be
saying to yourself right now you're
missing the whole point of the electoral
college is to protect the small states
from the big states give the small
states more voting power and the
presidential candidates will have to pay
them more attention in an election if
that's the goal of the Electoral College
it's failing spectacularly here's a
graph showing the number of visits the
presidential candidates paid to each of
the states in the last two months of the
previous election if it looks like there
are a few states miss
you're right only 18 of the 50 states
received even a single visit from a
candidate and just two of those states
main in New Hampshire have very small
populations the area of the country with
the most small states is conspicuously
missing the Electoral College doesn't
make candidates care about small states
but interestingly the biggest states
California Texas and New York are
missing as well so what's going on
looking closer just four states Ohio
Florida Pennsylvania and Virginia
received a majority of the candidates
attention during the election and if you
follow the money it's the same story
why do candidates spend so much money
and time in so few states because the
way the Electoral College works forces
them to do so the elections are
winner-take-all as long as a candidate
gets just over 50% of the popular vote
in a state he wins 100 percent of that
state's electoral votes that means
winning by millions of citizens votes is
no better than winning by a single vote
so candidates are safe to ignore states
where they pull with big margins instead
the Electoral College makes candidates
intensely interested in the needs of
just a few states with close races to
the detriment of almost all Americans
which is why it should be abolished but
wait you might say when abolishing the
Electoral College and voting directly
for president caused candidates to spend
all their time in big cities that
wouldn't be fair to most Americans
either this sounds like a reasonable
fear but ignores the mathematical
reality of population distribution there
are three hundred nine million people in
the United States only eight million of
which live in New York the largest city
by far that's 2.6 percent of the total
population but after New York the size
of cities drops fast la has 3.8 million
people and Chicago has 2.7 but you can't
even make it to the tenth biggest city
San Jose before you're under a million
people these top ten cities added
together are only seven point nine
percent of the popular vote hardly
enough to win an election and even
winning the next 90 biggest cities in
the United States all the way down to
Spokane is still not yet 20 percent of
the total population so unless there's a
city with a few hundred million people
hiding somewhere in America that's been
left out of the census the idea that a
candidate can just spend their campaign
jetting between New York LA and Chicago
while ignoring everyone else and still
become president is mathematically
ludicrous want to see the real way to
unfairly win how you can become
president with only 22% of the popular
vote by taking advantage of the
electoral college today don't believe
that's possible in a democracy
just watch here's the action plan win
the votes of the people who count the
most and ignored the people who count
the least start with Wyoming the state
where 0.18 percent of Americans live but
who gets zero point five six percent of
the electoral college votes for
presidents and because it's a
winner-take-all system you don't need
all of them to vote for you just half
plus one or 0.09 percent next up is the
District of Columbia we're winning point
one percent of the population gets you
an additional 0.5 6% of the electoral
college
then add in wins in Vermont and North
Dakota and Alaska
notice how the votes you're getting to
win the presidency go up much faster
than the percent of the population who
voted for you because of the electoral
colleges rules next is South Dakota
then Delaware Montana Rhode Island New
Hampshire Maine Hawaii Idaho Nebraska
West Virginia New Mexico Nevada Utah
Kansas Arkansas Mississippi Iowa
Connecticut Oklahoma Oregon Kentucky
Louisiana South Carolina Alabama
Colorado Minnesota Wisconsin Maryland
Missouri Tennessee Arizona Indiana
Massachusetts Virginia and New Jersey
congratulations by taking advantage of
the unfair rules and winning states not
people you've won a majority in the
electoral college
even though 78% of the population voted
against you
this is not democracy this is
indefensible while this particular
scenario is unlikely if you have a
voting system that allows losers to win
you shouldn't be surprised when they do
not once not twice but thrice in
American history the candidate with the
most votes from the people actually lost
because of the Electoral College three
errors in 55 plus elections is a failure
rate of 5 percent would anyone tolerate
a sport where by a quirk of the rules
there was a 5 percent chance that the
loser would win not likely given how
much more important electing the
President of the United States is that's
a rather dangerously high percentage of
the time to get it wrong if we abolish
the Electoral College and simply let
citizens vote for the president directly
all of these problems will go away and
everyone's vote will be equal
[Music]